tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel la
ceinture de sécurité réduit de 50% les
accidents mortels
c'est la principale conclusion d'une
étude réalisée sur 9 ans reconduction de
la grève des contrôleurs aériens
les conséquences pour les compagnies et
pour les passagers par catherine mamet
les américains gèle les avoirs iraniens
aux états unis
une décision plus politique
qu'économique car le dollar n'était pas
menacée bonsoir
attachez vos ceintures clic clac la
ceinture sauvent des vies elle réduit de
moitié les accidents mortels et cetera
voilà longtemps qu'on nous dit les
choses comme ceci mais jusqu'à
maintenant pour faire admettre aux
automobilistes le bon sens de ce qui est
devenu obligatoire ne l'oublions pas
depuis neuf ans et qui est maintenant
obligatoire aussi en ville nous avions
des campagnes de presse et des
statistiques annuelles
et bien aujourd'hui nous avons beaucoup
mieux nous avons un rapport qu'on peut
qualifier de scientifiques
un rapport qui répondent en partie aux
détracteurs de la ceinture de sécurité à
ceux qui demandaient et qu'est ce qui se
passe en cas d'incendié et si les
voitures tombent à l'eau et cetera
depuis neuf ans une équipe de médecins
dirigée par le professeur patel de
l'hôpital de garches a entrepris une
étude très complète sur la ceinture de
sécurité
ses qualités ses défauts ces
améliorations possibles
ils ont lu toutes les fiches d'accidents
qui se sont produits en france depuis
neuf ans ils en ont sélectionné trois
mille et les ont reconstitué ces
accidents en lob en laboratoire avec
l'aide de renault et peugeot le résultat
de cette étude
la voici résume le voici pardon résumé
par jean-pierre hamouz respectueux et
cette enquête l'équipe du professeur
patel a demandé depuis 1970 à toutes les
unités de police de gendarmerie et de
crs d'effectuer pour chaque accident
corporel une description très détaillée
circonstances et à des véhicules et des
personnes impliquées réalisation d'un
dossier photographique
toutes ces informations sont notés sur
une fiche à l'hôpital un bilan médical
des blessés est établi par les médecins
toutes ces fiches ont été centralisés et
analysé à l'hôpital de garches par une
équipe de médecins de techniciens de
l'automobile et de sociologues les
spécialistes ont retenu trois mille
accidents corporels qui leur semblaient
les plus représentatifs ces accidents
été reconstitué en laboratoire
vous pouvez voir sur ces images le film
de ces reconstitutions sur 3000 accident
1032 conducteur était ceinturé premières
constatations la ceinture réduit de 50%
les accidents mortels le crâne le thorax
et le bassin sont les parties du corps
les plus vulnérables les blessures
mortelles à la tête sont neuf fois moins
fréquentes chez les passagers ceinture
et dans la plupart des cas les
automobilistes qui ne sont pas saturés
subissent des traumatismes crâniens et
perde connaissance
ils sont en danger de mort en cas
d'incendié en revanche dans les 3000
accident à l'alizé tous les
automobilistes qui avaient leurs
ceintures ont eu le temps de quitter
leur voiture avant qu'elle ne prenne feu
dans trois accidents les voitures sont
tombés dans l'eau et ont été immergées
un seul conducteur qui avait sa ceinture
de sécurité est sorti indemme autre
constatation le port de la ceinture est
vite l'éjection et divise par cinq le
risque d'être tué lors de renversement
ou de tonneaux enfin les lésions à la
face et les fractures du bassin sont en
nette diminution depuis le port de la
ceinture en ville la gravité les blessés
a a diminué les blessent les morts qui
existait il ya neuf ans arrive vivent
maintenant à l'hôpital
cette étude qui est la plus complète qui
était fait dans le monde démontre
scientifiquement la nécessité du port de
la ceinture de sécurité
mais elle révèle également les limites
de cette ceinture ces limites sont liées
au seuil de tolérance de l'organisme
humain et à la construction de
l'automobile d'aujourd'hui grâce à cette
étude des solutions techniques nouvelles
des matériaux nouveaux sont testés par
les constructeurs automobiles pour
réduire autant que possible le nombre
des cas où la résistance de l'organisme
humain est dépassé
un tremblement de terre a éprouvé une
région reculée de l'iran aujourd'hui la
province du corps à 100 en augure au
nord-est du pays
dans les 13 villages touchés par ce
tremblement de terre il y aurait au
moins 250 morts selon l'agencé iranienne
de presse nous n'avons pas d'autres
détails
et tout à coup ce tremblement de terre
avec 250 morts apparaît comme un simple
fait divers banal dans une actualité ou
l'iran dans sa guerre économique et
psychologique avec l'amérique occupe
toujours la première place
il ya d'ailleurs des éléments
contradictoires dans ce conflit d'une
part un tout début de négociations
semblaient avoir des chances de
commencer sur cette situation tout à
fait extraordinaire la volonté de l'iran
d'échanger des otages de l'ambassade
américaine contre l'ex shah d'iran
toujours hospitalisé à new york
or dans le même temps la guerre
économique ou plutôt le bluff économique
montait d'un cran entre l'iran et les
etats-unis l'iran annonçait qu'elle
allait retirer ces dépôts bancaires en
amérique pour les transférer dans
d'autres pays plus sûr et cela après
l'arrêt des importations de brut
iraniens aux états unis est aussitôt les
états unis décidé de geler les avoirs
iraniens déposés dans les banques
américaines décision tout à fait
extraordinaire que nous allons mieux
examiner avec vous à la valeur oui eh
bien c'est la première fois seulement 20
ans la première concernait le vietnam
que les états unis gèlent ainsi des
avoirs étrangers en dollars william
miller le secrétaire américain au trésor
ici sur votre écran l'a souligné tout à
l'heure ajoutant que la décision
américaine avaient été comprises par les
principaux alliés des etats unis
il faut savoir que si le dollar est une
monnaie internationale ce n'est pas
seulement parce qu'elle appartient au
pays le plus riche du monde
elle fait partie des rares devises
qu'ils soient librement transférable et
convertibles avec le franc suisse
le marquer maintenant la livre
britannique alors pourquoi jimmy carter
at il pris le risque de ternir l'image
de l'amérique terre d'asile des capitaux
et de leur libre rapatriement en fait la
décision iranienne ne menaçait ni le
dollar ni les marchés mondiaux des
capitaux les avoirs iraniens de l'ars
s'élève à 12 milliards dont à peine plus
de cinq seraient placés dans les banques
américaines
c'est une goutte d'eau par rapport aux
quelques 500 milliards de dollars bas
hader recensés dans le monde imaginez
que rien qu'à paris au minimum 2
milliards de dollars change de mains
chaque jour bien sûr les marchés des
changes aurait réagi à des conversions
massives de dollar en d'autres devises
mais l'iran n'avait même pas la
possibilité de les retirer en une fois
des banques américaines
la plus grande partie de ces dépôts est
en place et à terme alors pourquoi la
décision de jimmy carter la réponse
n'est pas me semble-t-il technique mais
politique
le président américain de paraître fort
face à son opinion publique
alors maintenant si le chat le demander
il devrait trouver plusieurs pays
d'accueil l'egypte le mexique entre
autres mais la question qui se pose
depuis le début de la prise d'otages à
téhéran est la suivante est il certain
que le départ du shah arrangera les
choses et d'autre part sa santé lui
permettait de quitter l'hôpital de
washington dominique bromberger on
l'appelle le patient du 17e étage à
l'hôpital cornell de new york c'est là
qu'il occupe un appartement dont la
location à elle seule lui revient à 4000
francs par jour c'est là qu'il a subi
une opération de la vésicule biliaire et
pour le traitent par radiothérapie pour
sa maladie la plus grave un cancer du
système lymphatique
quand le chat est arrivé à new york les
informations diffusées par son médecin
et par le département d'état ont donné à
entendre que son état s'était subitement
détériorée et qu'il était en danger
presqu'une médias aujourd'hui derrière
des portes bien gardé les médecins de
l'hôpital cornell et même le docteur
personnel du chat admettent que la
gravité de son état a été surestimée ce
que si un ganglion s'est développé dans
son cou l'opération n'est pas en soi
extraordinaire et que des patients
correctement traitées pour ce type de
cancer survivent plusieurs années enfin
que le chat pourrait être transportable
assez rapidement
aucun médecin ne se reprochera jamais de
s'être trompée par excès de précaution
mais si les iraniens voilà un complot
c'est qu'ils affirment avoir découvert à
l'ambassade américaine de téhéran
des documents indiquant que dès le début
d'automne le secrétaire d'état interrogé
son ambassadeur sur place sur les
éventuelles réactions que provoquerait
une arrivée du chat aux états unis début
octobre document que le département
d'état ne met pas sérieusement en cause
au moins jusqu'à présent
aujourd'hui deux choses semblent assez
clair un l'administration apparaissait à
peu près décidé depuis le mois de
septembre a donné asile au chat c'est
peut-être pourquoi elle n'a pas tenté
semble-t-il de vérifier très
sérieusement les affirmations du médecin
traitant du chat selon lesquelles celui
ci ne saurait être soigné qu'à new york
2 d'ici très peu de temps le chat sera
en état de voyager et son traitement
pourrait être poursuivi dans plusieurs
pays en france par exemple a dit avec un
sourire l'un des médecins de l'hôpital
de new york
dominique bromberger tf1 new york
en france par exemple avec un sourire
première nouvelle en tout cas cette
situation de plus en plus tendu entre
l'iran les états unis préoccupent de
nombreux pays
il en a été longuement question ce matin
au conseil des ministres à paris mais ça
n'a fait l'objet d'aucune information ou
commentaires officiels et d'autre part
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
tient à partir de maintenant des
consultations à huis clos
toujours sur le même sujet voilà près de
trois semaines que les aiguilleurs du
ciel perturbait le trafic aérien par des
grèves quotidienne et ça va continuer
puisque l'assemblée générale des
contrôleurs aériens a décidé la
reconduction du mouvement par 246 voix
contre 2 conséquence facile à prévoir et
bien une grande partie du trafic de
l'ensemble des compagnies aériennes
risquent d'être annulés au moins jusqu'à
la semaine prochaine si l'on se réfère à
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui où les
décollages ont été suspendus de 8 heures
à 19 heures alors faisons le point avec
catherine mamet sur ce qui va en
résulter pour les passagers pour les
compagnies aériennes bien sûr les
contrôleurs du trafic aérien ont donc
décidé de reconduire leur mouvement
jusqu'à leur prochaine assemblée
générale qui se tiendra lundi 19
novembre rappelons le ce conflit porte
essentiellement sur les conditions de
travail conditions telles disent les
aiguilleurs qu'elle menace la sécurité
des passagers conséquence de cette grève
pour ces derniers la suspension des vols
jeudi de 14 à 17 heures 30 vendredi de 8
heures à 19 heures samedi et dimanche de
14 à 17 heures 30 et lundi de 8 à 19
heures ce conflit a d'autre part des
répercussions économiques sur l'aéroport
de paris tout d'abord qui ne touche plus
ces redevances d'atterrissage et qui a
perdu depuis le début de la grève 15
millions de francs un manque à gagner
qui augmente chaque jour pour atteindre
actuellement un million de francs par
jour s'il n'y a pour l'instant aucune
conséquence pour le personnel de
l'aéroport de paris il n'en est pas de
même pour celui des compagnies aériennes
régionales touraine air transport afin
d'éviter un dépôt de bilan a mis depuis
hier son personnel au chômage technique
un exemple que s'apprête à suivre les
autres compagnies régionales dont air
alpes où air anjou qui ont déjà depuis
lundi interrompu leur exploitation
maintenant la situation s'aggrave du
fait de la non présentation des
passagers à l'embarquement du fait de
l'annulation des décollages qui
décourage la clientèle du fait également
de l'allongement des temps de service du
personnel en particulier du personnel
navigant les charges par conséquent
continuer à courir voire à augmenter et
les recettes diminuent on peut
considérer que maintenant et perdu 40 à
50% du chiffre d'affaires journalier et
à ce rythme les entreprises prendront au
fur à mesure de la survenance d
événements les décisions qu'imposent aux
dirigeants pour la sauvegarde de
l'entreprise et du personnel une
déperdition de recettes qui actuellement
avoisine un million par jour
eire france et air à terre aucune prise
de position pour l'instant mais des
décisions sont à l'étude en cas de
durcissement du conflit
en effet air inter perd 3 millions par
jour et air france a enregistré depuis
le 26 octobre 40 millions de pertes
sèches
une situation que ces compagnies ne
pourront supporter très longtemps et
puis on s'aperçoit que le grand
bénéficiaire de s'admirer avait bien
c'est la sncf ses réservations en wagons
lits ont augmenté de 20% depuis la grève
des depuis le début de la grève des
contrôleurs aériens
le budget de la france pour 1981 devra
bien être adopté par l'assemblée
nationale d'une manière ou d'une autre à
la fin de la semaine
or vous savez que dans la majorité le
rpr a dit qu'il s'abstiendrait de voter
ce budget s'il n'obtenait pas un certain
nombre de modifications et notamment une
réduction de 2 milliards des dépenses de
l'état doit y avoir une concertation
entre le gouvernement
et sagem et sa majorité est
naturellement plus particulièrement avec
le rpr et voici la position arrêtée ce
matin par le gouvernement si cette
concertation n'aboutissaient pas le
gouvernement de raymond barre engagerait
sa responsabilité c'est à dire poserait
la question de confiance
d'autre part le conseil des ministres a
adopté un programme de développement de
ce qu'on appelle le grand sud ouest sur
dix ans un programme qui sera annoncé
par le président de la république à
l'occasion de son voyage dans la région
midi-pyrénées voyage qui débutera demain
justement découvrons cette région midi
pyrénées c'est à tous ces problèmes avec
un h venez une région qui manque d'armes
et d'unité mais qui possède une
métropole régionale active toulouse cinq
cent mille habitants une région peu
peuplée
quelques chiffres qui parlent d'eux même
densité nationale 97 midi-pyrénées 58 21
% du territoire national mais 13% de la
population seulement une région qui a
toujours été victime d'un exode rural
massif ainsi l'ariège et l'aviron en un
siècle ont perdu la moitié de leurs
habitants une véritable saignée à
bonpoint pourtant aujourd'hui les 52
mille étudiants qui sont un espoir pour
la vie
en tout huit départements coincé entre
languedoc roussillon et aquitaine ou
pied des pyrénées
véritable cul-de-sac de l'europe un
aéroport moderne bien sûr mais des
liaisons routières et ferroviaires tout
à fait insuffisantes en 81 pourtant
l'autoroute 10 des deux mers bordeaux
toulouse narbonne sera achevée il jouera
peut-être le même rôle qui hier le canal
du midi pour désenclaver la région
avantage de cette situation géographique
beaucoup de barrages une
hydroélectricité abondante la région
dans ce domaine est largement
exportatrice une région qui connaît
aussi bien des difficultés
l'activité industrielle il tient encore
une part beaucoup trop faible 21 % de la
population active et des secteurs
entiers les plus traditionnels
évidemment sont en crise cuirs et peaux
textile métallurgie ou hier ainsi et
c'est un exemple parmi d'autres
decazeville agonie en 76 mille chômeurs
dans notre région c'est à dire et 8,8
pour cent du nombre de salariés
il ya eu 4 136 fermetures d'entreprises
dans les îles salomon et aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une entreprise chez car
celle où à quelques jours la venue du
président de république dans notre
région eh bien on a non seulement un
sentiment de 200 personnes et d
exception pourtant beaucoup
d'industriels ne s'avouent pas vaincus
ne baisse pas les bras
s'adapte avec de petites unités de
production et des produits plus
sophistiqués avec lesquels la
concurrence du tiers-monde est
négligeable
et puis tout autour de toulouse se sont
installés des industries à technologie
très avancée télécommunication
informatique et surtout surtout
aéronautique
vingt mille personnes travaillent dans
ce secteur la moitié en comptant les
sous-traitants participent au programme
airbus airbus une véritable locomotive
économique pour toute la région
même si certains trouvent qu'elle ne va
pas assez vite
jusqu'à quand va-t-on conte sur des
airbus bienne au delà de 1990 et
probablement au delà de 1995
ça représentera combien d'appareils à
cette date et à cette date certainement
plus de 1000 avions peut-être mills un
sac
en fait le pays pyrénées une région
essentiellement touristique et agricole
polyculture céréales blé maïs colza
élevage aussi vaches des moutons ça
dépend des régions mais les rendements
ne sont pas extraordinaires et le
secteur agroalimentaire surtout est
encore ridiculement sous développés même
s'il ya deux brillantes exception tout
le monde connaît dans ce domaine le nom
du milliardaire rouge c'est ainsi qu'on
l'appelle monsieur doumeng et
l'élargissement du marché commun et bien
les industriels le voit plutôt d'un bon
oeil
après tout espagnol et portugais sont
des clients potentiels
compte tenu du calendrier des données et
dans l'école a quand même l'habitude de
travailler d'un système de concurrence
si on connaît on est payé pour ça
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui nous
véritale en oeuvre du tout les
agriculteurs sont plus inquiet et
surtout les producteurs de fruits et
légumes du côté de montauban où les
viticulteurs de cahors une attitude qui
n'a cependant aucun rapport avec celles
de leurs voisins du languedoc roussillon
qui eux sont persuadés qu'avec l'arrivée
de l'espagne et du portugal
ils vont avoir tout simplement le
couteau sous la gorge
l'élargissement de l'europe pour nous
c'est un peu la situation des petits
faits là au bord du barrage d'assouan à
qui on dirait le barrage va casser
apprend à nager c'est pour calmer ces
inquiétudes et permettre à la région de
réagir et de mieux préparer son avenir
c'est pour lui donner les moyens de
faire front avec plus de sérénité à
l'élargissement du marché commun que le
gouvernement a préparé en collaboration
avec les élus et les responsables
régionaux un plan décennal de
développement du grand sud ouest
un plan dont le président de la
république dévoilera les grandes lignes
à mazamet mazamet centre géographique de
ce grand sud ouest
voilà mais avant d'annoncer le plan pour
le grand sud-ouest à mazamet samedi le
président de la république sera passé
successivement par saint girons foix
rodez villefranche de rouergue chez
robert fabre et toulouse
un mot encore on a évoqué l' airbus dans
le reportage que vous venez de voir et
bien le conseil des ministres ce matin
adopté un programme d'investissement de
300 millions de francs pour l'année
prochaine et cela pour faire passer la
cadence de production de trois airbus
par mois à huit airbus par mois dans
quatre ans jean claude narcy avec vous
les autres nouvelles de ce journal le
président valéry giscard d'estaing a
visité cet après midi le conseil d'état
en compagnie du premier ministre et du
garde des sceaux
dans son discours le président de la
république a rendu hommage à cette
institution il a également appelé l'état
les administrations et les juridictions
à conjuguer leurs efforts pour faire
face à l'augmentation des affaires dont
les tribunaux sont saisis
la journée d'action cgt et cfdt pour la
réduction de la durée du travail a été
diversement suivie aujourd'hui a été
marquée dans le secteur privé en tous
les cas principalement par des arrêts de
travail d'une heure à deux heures et par
des délégations auprès des chambres
patronales
demain ultime rencontre entre le cnpf et
les syndicats pour négocier sur la durée
du travail chez alstom atlantique call
usine de sainte-foy en quelques 200
ouvriers sur les 2000 ont pu reprendre
le travail ce matin après que l'usiné
était évacué la nuit dernière
alstom belfort la grève se poursuit et
l'on attend des premiers contacts et ils
sont prévues pour demain matin avec
monsieur salomon le médiateur chargé de
trouver une solution au conflit qui dure
je vous le rappelle depuis deux mois
monsieur salomon a une semaine pour
déposer ses conclusions en fin de ma
belle fort sera une ville fermée bloquer
les axes principaux seront interdits par
les syndicats à la circulation
messieurs françois giscard d'estaing et
jacques qu'il dise car destin un cousin
du président de la république ont
assigné en diffamation le directeur du
canard enchaîné monsieur fressoz et
monsieur claude angeli et journalistes à
la suite de l'article publié le 10
octobre dernier et les mettant en cause
dans la sphère des diamants de bokassa
monsieur françois mitterrand convoqués
pour être interrogé cet après-midi sur
la sphère de radio riposte par monsieur
lecante doyen des juges d'instruction du
tribunal de paris ne s'est pas présenté
il a affirmé avoir déjà tout dit sur
cette affaire
suite du suicide de robert boulin
georges marchais a déclaré à l'émission
face au public de france inter rien ne
saurait justifier les campagnes d'
attaques personnelles tout cela
m'inspire mépris et d'égout fin de
citation
un nouveau gouverneur pour la banque de
france monsieur renaud de la janière
succède à monsieur bernard clap team
renault de la janière qui a appartenu au
cabinet d'antoine pinay lorsqu'il était
ministre finances a été également
directeur au ministère des finances
un nouveau candidat officiel pour les
élections présidentielles américaines
cette fois du côté républicain
il s'agit de l'ancien sénateur de
californie ronald reagan ancienne
vedette de cinéma
il espère bien obtenir l'investiture de
son parti le parti républicain pour
affronter jimmy carter ou ted kennedy
l'an prochain le prix international de
journalisme bernard cabannes 79 été
remis par le journaliste et sociologue
raymond aron membre de l'institut à jean
pierre gallois âgé de 32 ans il est
correspondant à hanoi de l' agence
france-presse
et c'est pour ses articles sur le
cambodge qui lui vient d'être décoré de
7,2 ce prix tf1 vient de recevoir deux
prix décerné par radio monte carlo il
s'agit des galets d'or qui ont été remis
à notre ami maurice bruzac pour son
magazine expression et à igor et grichka
bogdanoff pour l'émission de
science-fiction temps x au cours d'une
compétition dans les rapides de santa
elena regardez bien ces images au
mexique
le pilote d'un bateau équipé d'un moteur
à turbine a perdu le contrôle de son
engin qui a pénétré vais le voir à plus
de 100 kilomètres heure dans la foule
des spectateurs en tuant deux
spectateurs et en blessant dix
où
donc bilan deux morts et dix blessés
enfin pour gagner le loto il fallait
jouer le 5 le 24 vous le voyez sur votre
écran le 25
le 38 le 44 et le 48 avec comme numéro
complémentaire le 35 le temps les
températures continuent à baisser comme
vous pouvez le voir sur ce tableau
le froid est grelet va d'ailleurs
persiste et demain le temps sera
variable y aura de nombreuses averses
parfois assez fortes et parfois
accompagnées de grêle ou de neige s'il
ya des éclaircies seront de courte durée
c près de la méditerranée quels sont les
plus belles et les vents resteront assez
fort sur tout le pays
dans l'intérieur et aussi forts prennent
près des côtes sur les côtes et surtout
en mer dans le midi toujours du mistral
et de tramontane 60 personnalités de
renommée internationale des prix nobel
d'anciens responsables politiques des
intellectuels des artistes sont réunis
depuis lundi au siège de l'unesco pour
parler de l'avenir de la paix de
l'unesco à paris il n'y a pas de sujet
plus essentiel pour l'avenir de
l'humanité que l'avenir de la paix ces
débats déboucheront sur des
recommandations
il appartiendra aux politiques ensuite
de prendre ou non ses voeux en
considération et là dessus même si on
peut se réjouir d'une aussi riche en
rencontres inspiré par la philosophie et
les sciences humaines ya tout lieu
d'être malheureusement sceptiques sur
son efficacité
ces personnalités dont je viens de vous
parler ont pris aujourd'hui un bain de
jouvence ou même une leçon de concorde
ils ont participé en effet à
l'installation de l'arbre de vie un beau
nom pour une oeuvre collective réalisée
par dix enfants de 5 ans à 12 ans
lauréat du récent concours mondial de
dessins d'enfants et il paraît que pour
peindre et construire ensemble cet arbre
de vie le petit chinois le petit
péruvien le petit japonais le petit
danois et d'autres n'ont eu aucune
difficulté de communication
c'est ça la leçon reportage sur l'arbre
de vie jacques collet par sat arbre de
vie qu'ils ont construit et décorer les
enfants portent aux adultes une question
comment vivrons-nous en
mille questions pas si naïve puisqu'elle
correspond au thème des travaux qui
réunissent à l'unesco les représentants
des pays que préoccupe le sort de la
paix l'arbre de vie est inspiré du
baobab dans lequel chaque branche
représente l'histoire de la vie imaginée
par chacun de ses enfants
ce symbole rappelle aux hommes
d'aujourd'hui le terrible danger devant
lequel se trouve l'humanité sans
qu'elles en aient conscience car il n'y
a pas que la guerre nucléaire aux
travaux n'ont abouti à rien
au moins que nous puissions maintenant
aboutir un désarmement général et
complet à moins d'une opposition changer
l'attitude des gouvernements vis-à-vis
les armes et vis-à-vis les armements un
mois que nous puissons live et à faire
preuve est complètement l'utilisation
d'armes nucléaires
avec ses dix enfants quatre prix nobel
des écrivains des chercheurs des
cinéastes d'anciens chefs d'état des
poètes même venus d'horizons
géographiques et politiques très
différents pose cette question toute
simple l'humanité veut-elle encore vivre
pour combattre ce doute
il faut toute la foi et la force de
conviction de lord baker qui a plus de
90 ans entreprend cette véritable
croisade pour la paix nous sommes en
présence de guerre conventionnelle kitty
des milliers d'êtres humains presque
chaque jour
il faut en finir avec le militarisme
avec les théories t10 oisillons avec les
folies monumentale qui constituent les
armements d'aujourd'hui c'est une chose
très curie reste l'homme dans la rue
s'intéressent au foot on s'intéresse au
théâtre au cinéma aux films à la
télévision
il ne s'intéresse pas aux obsessions de
vie et de mort mais on va le réveiller
on va faire une propagande d'une
éducation mondiale pour
lui faire comprendre qu'il a maintenant
in choix ym choix entre un monde qui s'y
lie à la guerre deviendra aussi désert
aussi silencieuse que la lune est en
manque des amendes qui pourraient être
glorieux
voilà à méditer dernier journal joseph
poli
vers 23h15 merci de votre attention pour
nom de toute l'équipe de tf1 actualité
où les vaio la machine à laver est en
panne elle est toujours en femme d'un
dépanneur de quelques semaines on
changeantes du futur
à propos qu'est ce qu'elle a ma femme
que machine à laver
en fait rien ça fait longtemps qu'on l'a
j'en ai jamais entendu parler bougez pas
je trouve lamentable
hildebrand banque pour ne pas se tromper
à chacun ses plaisirs
à chacun ses fromages moelleux fromages
bleus prendraient tous sans exception
avec des herbes quoi avant le dessert
tous les jours vous et onctueux
bienfaits hérisson partage pour faire
plus d'un heureux offrons plus d'un
fromage avec le téléviseur couleur itp
océanique
vous n'êtes plus libre votre cassette
fait les commandites et et océanique est
encastrable elle fonctionne soit
incorporé soit à distance
vous pouvez aussi changer cette cassette
et jouer aux huit jeux de la cassette et
les matches où tu étais océane et
changer les programmes de votre
téléviseur en toute liberté avec le
téléviseur couleur it et et océanique à
cassette
voici un des six mille conseiller anti
gaspi
gratuitement il vous rend visite sur
votre demande et des têtes de tous les
nids de gaspi qui se cachent ces phrases
il voit l'isolation gerber en a partout
de lalala regard de la régulation
bon ça par exemple problème l'entretien
par contre c'est la fête il y en ait
fait un diagnostic moins d'argent à
gauche les travaux à faire et il le prix
que ça coûte
à droite ce que vous allez économiser
pour connaître les adresses de vos
conseillers anti gaspi écrivez à
diagnostic anti gaspi cedex 8075 310
paris brune car ça c'est un cador en
faire double vapeur double efficacité
alors fait coup double car 5 octobre au
mi décembre
vous gagnez 30 franc rentrant de
réduction si les français redoutent le
vapeur calor qu'alors 3 petit prix
n'hésite pas à jour de construire leur
maison
la première bricole son électricité
la deuxième s'est installé le chauffage
électrique oublie l'isolation et la
chaleur sans fin
vienne elle exige du matériel de qualité
nf et une bonne isolation poser suivant
les règles de l'art il suit les conseils
promotelec nous est revenue la seconde
on se ruine en chauffage la première
échappe de justesse à un incendie
download et se réfugie chez la troisième
où elle coule encore des gens heureux
économie sécurité
si vous allez conseil promotelec
documentation gratuite
après l'intérêt c'est dingue 825 souvent
de 15,3 à paris brune robot minute seb
trois accessoires seulement il fait tout
de délicieux potages des frites fine des
steaks hachés des vrais la patte de vos
gâteaux les ornaises la mayonnaise rap
et émincez les crudités robot minute seb
trois accessoires seulement et il fait
tout silencieusement seb je vous
rappelle qu'à 22h20 pierre dumayet dans
son émission à mémoire bien rangée nous
emmènera ce soir une dernière fois la
bibliothèque nationale mais pour le
moment
l'inspecteur mène l'enquêté vous savez
je vous le rappelle que cette émission
vous la fête avec nous et que vous y
jouer un très grand rôle en effet il
n'ya que vous ce soir qui puissiez venir
en aide dans notre candidat si vous le
voyez piétiner un petit peu dans ce look
est alors si vous repérez au ou
plusieurs indices qui vous paraissent
importants est susceptible de le mettre
sur la voie je vous demande vraiment
instamment de téléphoner très vite svp
je vous donnerai numéro de téléphone
tout à l'heure la sbp vous demandez
claudine pas vous louis bozon et vous
leur communiqué le ou les détails qui
vous paraissent importants et qui seront
susceptibles donc de mettre notre
candidat sur la voie notre candidat de
ce soir s'appelle jean luc chameaux les
tec l'usiné de son métier comme son père
et je vais tout de suite entrer en
liaison avec lui puisque lui se trouve
sur un studio buttes chaumont et moi je
suis à cognac jay mais nous allons
parler dont par duplex alors jean-luc
bonsoir nizon soir je suis très heureuse
jean l'huile de faire votre connaissance
on ne peut pas dire jean luc que vous
ayez un métier qui prédispose à résoudre
des énigmes policières
oui oui forcément enfin disons que
justement parce que ce métier que je
fais qui me plaît beaucoup
me permet justement de résoudre quelques
énigmes à temps perdu
oui c'est donc un métier qui vous laisse
le temps de beaucoup lire peut-être oui
on peut hein
et à part la lecture est ce que vous
avez d'autres violon d'ingres est-ce que
vous jouer à certains jeux qui nous
permettent de développer ce sens de
l'analyse à wii avec ma femme bien sûr
je joue aux échecs scrabble dites moi
j'en lis qu'est ce qui vous a
particulièrement intéressé dans cette
émission qu'est ce qui vous a amené à
poser votre candidature et à participer
à cette émission ce soir ce qui m'y
emmener difficile à répondre vous savez
l'attrait du jeu sur tout et surtout la
précision de votre âge vous n'êtes pas
vous n'êtes pas effrayé de d'avoir à
tenir l'antenne une heure et demie plus
d'une heure et demie tout seul ce soit
en direct je le précise devant tant de
millions de téléspectateurs avec le pas
de deux charmantes petites filles et je
suppose que toute votre petite famille
doit se trouver ce soir devant le poste
de télévision comme nous prêts à vous
suivre prêts à vous regardez bien sûr
alors j'espère que vous allez faire en
sorte que quel soit très très fier de
vous 1
je vous souhaite bonne chance jean luc
et puis compter sur nous on est tous là
pour vous aider
d'accord mais revoir leur vie alors
téléspectateurs il me reste plus qu'à
vous dire une chose à vos postes
maintenant regardez bien je sais qu'il y
en a parmi vous qui sont
particulièrement forts et pratiquement
incollables dans ce genre d'exercice
alors c'est vraiment le moment de de
nous aider à repérer bien les indices et
dès que vous en possédez un ou plusieurs
vous appelez le 787
11 11 et vous communiquez le ou les
détails importants à claudine pas vous à
louis bozon alors c'est bernard golay
qui dirige toutes les opérations lui est
en place et par son poste je vous laisse
tout de suite en sa compagnie
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée et
que l' enquête commence
non
schneider une preuve d'exigence la vie
le moteur de la france c'est vous
commerçants industriels prestataires de
services défendez et construisez
l'avenir voter jusqu'au 15 novembre par
correspondance pour élire vos
représentants aux chambres de commerce
et d'industrie
mercredi 21 novembre à 20h35 sur tf1
bonsoir raymond barre engagera la
responsabilité de son gouvernement sur
le vote du budget ainsi en a décidé le
conseil des ministres à moins que à
moins que les entretiens qui vont avoir
lieu à matignon dès demain avec le rpr
aboutissent à un accord sur les fameux
deux milliards d'économies
alors le scénario est bien celui que
l'on avait imaginé
sur le plan social les jours passent les
conflits demeurent à belfort chez alstom
on est dans l'expectative après la
nomination d'un expert d'un conciliateur
mais les syndicats durcissent leur
action en organisant demain une journée
belfort bloque les contrôleurs aériens
poursuivre leur grève au moins jusqu'à
lundi et la pagaille continue d'aller
dans les aéroports nous parlerons du
dernier film de juan bardem les sept
jours de janvier avec l'auteur qui est
avec nous sur le plateau et dans le
dossier iranien
les projecteurs sont maintenant braqués
sur lot n y est on a un peu tendance à
oublier que des hommes sont toujours
enfermés dans leur masse à l'amérique
thierry de scitivaux notre envoyé
spécial à terre est retourné dans cette
ambassade au terme de cette 11e journée
de détention que peuvent penser les 60
otages détenus pieds et poings liés
dans différents bâtiments de l'ambassade
américaine certes ils ont reçu la visite
de six personnalités non iranienne qui
leur ont assuré que le maximum sera fait
pour leur libération
on leur a fait signer des pétitions mais
totalement coupée des nouvelles du monde
extérieur ils doivent se demander si on
les a pas oubliés d'autant plus que les
étudiants leur ont dit qu'il pourrait
rester des semaines voire devra les
otages de la population si le président
carter ne cédait pas
l'occupation de l'ambassade des états
unis à ressouder les iraniens autour de
l'imam khomeiny la campagne anti
américaines les plus généralement acquis
impérialistes trouve considérable
résonance dans la population irakienne
aussi peut-on penser légitimement que
cette occupation de trouvera fin que
lorsque les buts politique de l'imam
khomeiny seront atteints
thierry de scitivaux paix afin terran
pendant ce temps les preuves de bras de
fer puisque c'est l'expression à la mode
continue entre les etats-unis et l'iran
elle avait commencé vous en souvenez par
l'expulsion de certains étudiants
iraniens
puis par l'embargo du président carter
sur le pétrole iranien
furieux d'être pris de vitesse khomeiny
se déchaînaient aujourd'hui est décidé
de demander le transfert en iran de tous
les avoirs iraniens placés dans les
banques des amériques 12 milliards de
dollars c'est-à-dire 54 milliards de
francs trente minutes plus tard les
états unis je lai les avoirs iraniens
qu'ils estimaient non plus à 12 mai à 6
milliards de dollars la fortune du ch a
considéré comme une personne privée par
les américains nés pendant les faits
visés par cette mesure
et puis voici maintenant que la partie
de poker entre téhéran et washington se
poursuit à l'onu
ce soir le conseil de sécurité se réunit
à huit clos en présence de monsieur
cyrus vance le ministre affaires
étrangères et des états unis
mais monsieur bani sadr le nouvel homme
fort iranien a manifesté son intention
d'aller devant ce conseil pour plaider
son dossier
si les otages américains sur libéré
réplique les etats-unis qui veulent
contrer les iraniens sur le plan
diplomatique et selon les informations
qui nous parviennent
ce soir de washington washington
obtiendra sans doute satisfaction on en
est là ce soir mais
c'est demain que le président de la
république par pour le midi pyrénées en
commençant ce voyage de travail par
l'ariège ce matin le conseil des
ministres a adopté le programme de
développement de 10 ans du grand sud
ouest
mais c'est pour l'instant top secret
valéry giscard d'estaing le dévoilera ce
plan lui même au cours de son voyage
qu'attendent les élus de ce plan voici
l'opinion de robert fabre
l'ancien leader des radicaux de gauche
qui est député maire de villefranche de
rouergue donc l'effort de solidarité la
nation s'exerce dans le sens d'un
équipement possible de notre région dont
ils ont grand besoin pour faire d'abord
une sorte de rattrapage
mais une fois ce rattrapage effectué il
faut que l'effort supplémentaire ne soit
accordé pour faire face à l'entrée
d'espagne dans le marché commun qui
apporte un certains nombre davantage en
descente prend peut-être à notre profit
l'équilibré européen mais aussi qu'ils
apportent un simple aux difficultés
qu'il faudra surmonter
c'est demain que raymond barre recevra
une délégation politique du rpr
obtiendra-t-elle satisfaction sur les
deux milliards d'économies
c'est la certitude par contre j'ai chine
où le président du groupe udf à
l'assemblée est sorti assez satisfait
aujourd'hui du cabinet du premier
ministre
je crois que le gouvernement est il dit
peut répondre assez favorablement à nos
demandes
alors ces demandes il y en a deux
principales révision des tranches du
barème de l'impôt sur le revenu et
création d'un groupe de travail
permanent chargé de réexaminer les
crédits budgétaires qui sont reconduits
automatiquement chaque année sans doute
pour faire des économies
alors si samedi raymond barre à les
difficultés avec sa majorité et bien ce
sera
l'article 49 de la constitution il
engagera sa responsabilité et celle de
son gouvernement sur son budget dans ce
cas si aucune motion de censure n'est
déposé le budget est adopté sans vie
alors un pronostic réseau nar il y aura
une motion de censure de l'opposition le
rpr ne la votera pas et la crise sera
évité ce soir au cours de l'émission de
france inter face au public
georges marchais a redit une nouvelle
fois à propos du suicide de robert
boulin que rien ne serait justifiée les
campagnes de disques
edit personnel campagne nourrit
d'information sans preuve selon lui et
campagne d'allusions perfide et puis il
a parlé des élections présidentielles
brièvement mais avec détermination comme
vous allez le voir ce qui concerne le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle le parti le candidat du
parti communiste français va au combat
pour arriver en tête et salle à manger
si les pentes
c'est pas joli tic avec des si c'est
demain que le patronat et syndicats
reprennent leurs négociations sur la
durée du travail est encore beaucoup de
marge entre les positions des uns des
autres mais un certain optimisme est
dans l'air par contre il faut être plus
prudent pour les deux conflits en cours
en ce qui concerne alstom monsieur
matteoli le nouveau ministre du travail
a annoncé à l'assemblée nationale qu'il
présenterait lui même la fin de la
semaine ou deux parties les conclusions
de l'expert monsieur salma les syndicats
organisent demain à belfort une
opération ville bloquée dans un climat
d'inquiétude et contrôleur aérien de la
région nord ont reconduit leur grève
jusqu'à lundi au moins il n'y aura donc
pas de décollage de main entre 11h et
17h
y'en aura pas vendredi entre 8h et 19h
samedi et dimanche entre 13h et 17h 30
et lundi entre 8h et 19h les contrôleurs
aériens des autres régions se
prononceront demain et après demain sur
la poursuite de leur gré le président de
la république était aujourd'hui au
conseil d'état il a rendu hommage à
cette juridiction disant ceci le conseil
d'état apporte la démonstration propre à
notre système administratif colom n'est
libre que dans un état libre avec un
juge libre et indépendant aux états unis
monsieur ronald reagan l'ancien
gouverneur la californie est à son tour
candidat à la candidature il a décidé en
effet de solliciter l'investiture du
parti républicain ronald reagan se situe
à la droite de ce parti et cet américain
qui a le style disons de john wayne nous
promet une campagne pittoresque s'il
fait la course à la maison blanche de
washington notre correspondant permanent
dominique bromberger
ronald reagan
ancien commentateur sportif ancien
comédien ancien gouverneur de californie
l'enfant chéri des milieux conservateurs
des états unis l'homme qui en 76 failli
ravir l'investiture du parti républicain
gerald ford
ronald reagan est reparti en campagne et
il est à l'heure actuelle le grand
favori pour devenir celui qui s'opposera
au vainqueur du duel carter kennedy pour
annoncer que je suis candidat à
l'investiture du parti républicain et
pourrait être élu président des états
unis
c'est à une mise en scène soigneusement
préparée que l'on a pu assister à cette
occasion tandis que 75 stations
délégation simultanément à reggane
annoncé aussi sa candidat e millions de
francs l'argent ne manque pas du côté du
candidat reggane pendant ce temps à new
york comme pour faire contrepoids aux
difficultés familiales qu'elle ait dit
l'ancien gouverneur présenter tous les
siens la famille heureuse comme les
américains en même temps l'image
et puis il y avait les gens du spectacle
il ya 35 ans très connu est un vrai ami
le président de
les acteurs vous avez été formidables
dans ce métier et pour moi il a
l'expérience
il a beaucoup d'intelligence à vassan
vire un peu comment on l'entend mais
maintenant ils house aussi sur
l'immaturité des failles
maintenant je crois qu'il faut quelqu'un
quitte tout s'est très très bien
commander en ligne connaissent conduire
oui avoir de la poigne en quelques sur
cette histoire
aussi tout le dit déterminé un dîner
entre parenthèses à 2500 francs le
couvert le candidat prenait le chemin de
washington pour y développer
quelques-uns des thèmes de sa politique
regan n'a pas changé ses premiers mots
étaient pour accuser carter de faire
trop de concessions aux soviétiques et
pour affirmer que la révolution en iran
aurait pu être arrêté par la new york la
nuit dernière
washington ce matin deux étapes
aujourd'hui en nouvelle angleterre et
retour à new york dans la soirée puis
plus de 15000 km et cette ville en
l'espace de trois jours tel est
l'itinéraire de ronald reagan
à chacun son passé tout comme kennedy
doit se débattre avec la sphère de
chappaquiddick carter avec ses
incertitudes et ces échecs reagan doit
démontrer qu'à 68 ans il peut encore
faire un candidat et éventuellement un
président capable de faire face aux
tâches les plus durs dominique
bromberger tf1 washington est maintenant
le film de juan antonio bardem les sept
jours de janvier avec manuel angel lg à
madeleine robinson et jacques françois
c'est un film sur l'espagne
d'aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'espagnols surtout des jeunes
sont encore hostile à la démocratisation
de l'espagne luis maria étudiants bonne
famille fils d'un héros des campagnes
franquiste fait partie de ceux là
il voudrait que l'armée et reviennent au
pouvoir et rien ne l'arrêtera
pour y parvenir voici un extrait de ce
film entre ne t'avise pas de faire une
manne à aller tous contre le mur un
rythme aussi contre le mur à mur
j'ai dit plus haut les mains
pour une à barran et si il n'y a
personne de ce nom allait bien serré
contre le mur à l'est eh bien on vos
petites mains bien les mains plus haut
à
et
e
juan antonio bardem votre film est basé
sur des faits réels
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler ce
qu'ont été ses sept jours de janvier le
les événements tragiques et a eu lieu en
espagne magri la dernière semaine
janvier mini 110c lundi 7
je sais dans le ville de raconter tout
ça semaine d'une importance historique
fondamentale pour le devenir de la jeune
démocratie espagnole
il ya beaucoup de jeunes étudiants comme
celui de votre film en espagne n'est pas
caricatural non je sais y ait tout
m'efforce d'essayer de faire en fil
paniqué de tous de 12 il ya d'essayer de
voix de raison le plus objective
analytique
pourquoi ce genre de l'ordre vont ainsi
et ils sont nostalgiques du pouvoir
franquiste et ils veulent déstabiliser
les régimes démocratiques rituel est
traîné l'armée au pouvoir
et pourquoi d'après vous parce que ils
ont encore dans cette nostalgie de la
nature il pense que l'espagne est un
pays et spécialement signalé par dieu
pour de france à la culture aussi un
talent et tout le blabla du fasciste
c'est qu'est-ce qui a changé depuis la
mort de franco pour un cinéaste
vous avez été soumis à la censure bon la
chose de fondamental c'est que le peuple
espagnol est acquis la liberté
elle est pour nous le cinéaste pour le
chanter les clubs pour tout il ya la
liberté d'expression il ya un peu plus
de censure politique dont on est libre
de faire secret on prend et on veut le
problème que vont se tourner maintenant
ses quais à plus de liberté de création
il ya aussi un problème assez difficile
à résoudre tous les problèmes d'ordre
des structures que la mixer le problème
de la liberté du fusion parce que bien
sûr vous êtes libres de le faire
n'importe quel film mais les programmes
dédiés diffuser ses films mais c'est un
problème assez difficile parce qu'en
général les voies de diffusion sont
bloqués par la plus grands et puissants
et du str si ma thérapie mondiales et
d'aller par l'industrie américaine
le problème tout à fait générale en
europe je pense qu'en france qu'en
italie en angleterre on va là n'est pas
le problème mais vous n'aviez aucune
difficulté pour tourner votre fils
ponctuellement que est votre prochain
film il sera politique aussi moi je
dirais c'est à historique aussi j'essaie
de faire un film qui traitera sur leur
prescient d'irena de 1936 l'assassinât
des bus poète federico garcia note
j'en remercie les images que vous allez
voir ne sont pas extraite d'un film
malheureusement elles sont réelles et
tragique
la scène se passe au mexique dans les
rapides de santa elena
au cours d'une compétition de hors bord
le pilote d'un bateau équipé d'un moteur
à turbine perd le contrôle de son
et peinait à plus de 100 kilomètres à
l'heure dans la file
regardez
non
plus
le bilan est lourd deux morts et six
blessés sont des faits est encore à
l'honneur maurice bruzac pour le
magazine expression et igor et grichka
bogdanoff pour l'émission de
science-fiction temps x viennent de
recevoir les galets d'or de radio monte
carlo le temps maintenant pour terminer
les températures vont continuer à
baisser la ce temps variable un peu
partout il y aura de nombreuses averses
parfois accompagnées de grêle ou de
neige les exercices seront de courte
durée mais c'est dans le midi où elles
seront les plus belles bonsoir prochaine
édition de tf1 actualité demain 13h avec
yves mourousi je vous remercie d'avoir
passé cette soirée avec nous sur tf1
d'être resté avec nous jusqu'à
maintenant nos émissions sont terminées
mais avant de vous quitter permettez moi
de vous rappeler de vous de vous
signaler que consacreront notre soirée
de demain à mon ami gaylord est mon ami
gay lors c'est une toute nouvelle série
qui a été réalisé par pierre goûtas ce
d'après les romans d'eric malpas est mon
ami taylor et bien c'est l'histoire d'un
bon petit diable moderne ce sont les
aventures et les mésaventures d'un la
fraude chouchou c'est romain 30 blot qui
est le principal interprète de cette
série avec christian barbier qui lui
jouera le rôle de son grand papa dans
mon ami qu'est l'or christian barbier
que vous retrouvez chaque samedi dans
notre samedi après midi dans le cadre de
nos samedis après midi dans l'homme du
picardie
ensuite ce sera l'événement demain soir
sur tf1 depuis notre dernier journal
mais après les régionales nos émissions
ne sont pas terminées nous vous
proposerons de terminer la soirée en
regardant un très bon film policier qui
a pour titre la poursuite implacable et
dont les principaux interprètes
ce sont de grands acteurs italiens c'est
un film policier
et il y aura fabio testi frédéric de
pasquale oliver reed agostina bélie par
la pita corps et les jambes
nos émissions reprendront demain sur tf1
comme d'habitude comme chaque jour avec
notre jeu répond sato qui sera suivie
2010 première du journal de 13 heures et
puis je vous signale que demain après
midi comme chaque jeudi dans le cadre de
nos 24 jeudi vous pourrez voir un grand
documentaire de 16 heures à 17 heures
c'est un documentaire que nous
diffusions spécialement à l'intention de
nos jeunes amis mais ils vous
intéressera sûrement vous aussi s'agira
demain de la france de michel et pour le
moment je vous souhaite à toutes et à
tous une très bonne nuit dormait d'y
infecte beaux rêves et à demain sur tf1
j'espère